[Musique]
apple quand arrive quand je t'appelle
ton avis pourquoi j'ai mis à part
pourtant j'ai vu je veux des aventures
je vous dirais la chambre le bureau la
salle de bain avec la baignoire sabot
comme à l'époque mais du coup on mange
dans la baignoire
ça c'est de plus en plus on joue un peu
plus accros aux réseaux sociaux
pas forcément de postes de postes mais
vraiment de regard de regard je peux
regarder des vidéos un stade de gamelles
de vidéos de chats des vidéos d'eux
voilà je peux regarder vraiment des
vidéos pendant des heures sans m'arrêter
et tant qu'on ne m'intéresse pas je peux
regarder ça très longtemps comme la tv
[Musique]
je travaille quand même beaucoup mes
textes je connais le texte maintenant
mon plus gros défaut c'est des fous
rires j'ai tellement de fou rire que du
coup des fois je vais parler mais genre
je vais vous dire un dégoût qu'il suffit
que tu fais là je suis venu rencontrer
mes nouveaux collègues
[Musique]
mais elle n'a pas tangué les rex à moi
moi j'avais plus de facilité moi j'avais
l'habitude avec des nids de ça on a
dansé ensemble a fait des tournées on se
connaît très bien on a une connexion de
toute manière donc
donc quoi qu'il arrive voilà c'était
c'était plus simple pour moi maintenant
c'était la première fois qu'elle faisait
la rencontre avec des noms de ça et
ça s'est plutôt bien passé hélas très
bien débrouillé franchement dans le film
voit pas la différence
je l'appelle tamara dans la vie donc
c'est que vraiment il ya quelque chose
c'est la même aussi naïve aussi drôle et
voilà une vraie tamara je suis très
sélectif sur les séries tant que j'en ai
pas vraiment entendu parler tous les
côtés je regarde pas donc là la dernière
que j'ai vu je crois pour dire ses 15
années papel bon c'est actuelle sans
être actuel en vrai ça fait un petit
moment et c'est parce que tout le monde
en parle maintenant et machin je me suis
dit allez je vais jeter un coup d'oeil
j'ai kiffé
et voilà mais sinon je regarde pas
entier moi je regarde plein de séries je
suis sur netflix sur les bio va tout ce
qui sort je regardais - le premier
épisode si j'aime pas là at-il il adore
je continue jusqu'au bout tamara trois
mois je veux un tamara 3 absolument dans
quelques années c'est jusque voilà
encore une fois là le 2 allée le voir
mais je vous promets qu'il est encore
plus drôle que l un est et je le trouve
mieux
qu'est ce qu'on va faire après ça je
sais pas moi donc
donc voilà si encore alec trouve une
idée de malades on la fera et on sera de
la partie
obligatoirement le bébé le mariage
durera ya plein de trucs non peu le le
boulot le taf
il ya plein de choses je pense qu'on a
plein d'idées on va on pourrait apporter
plein de choses mais voilà ça sera pas
tout de suite parce que si on veut faire
un truc un peu qui s'étale dans le temps
et encore une autre étape de la vie va
falloir qu'on grandisse ou qu'on se
grime et ça c'est fort on met une fausse
barre
si tu regarde un peu autour de toi tu
fais un quart plein de gens qui
connaissent
moi je t'aime et je t'aimerai toujours
je suis là depuis le début
c'est très gênant ce qui va se passer
quand arrive quand je rappelle qu'on est
pourquoi je suis mis à part pourtant
j'ai vu je veux garantir je veux du rêve
la chambre le bureau la salle de bain
avec la baignoire sabot comme à l'époque
je me dis qu'on mange dans la baignoire
ça c'est de plus en plus on peut pas
habiter avec wagner ger alors tu l'aimés
150 mètres carrés on trouvera jamais
qu'est-ce qui fait la jeune rencontrer
mes nouveaux collègues sapeurs de
recraqué c'est sa maman moi je m'en fous
de lui un c est un exemple j'ai réfléchi
ça va c'est pas comme si je n'avais
jamais vu un poil en fait elodie du faux
ça me fait quoi face à ce moment ce
parce que ça parfois que gens ici et
c'est un peu perdue au coeur ce match
apparaît également dit influencé étaient
clients des banques tu peux le faire
sortons bull qui perd demain tu peux
voir tout ce qu'elle fait tu peux
m'abonner mais aussi pour moi je deviens
points une vieille peau non danseuse
étoile c'est ça qu'on devient à 45
manière générale c'est quoi ça me loue
comme moi qui veulent que je parte par
franck sur un style puisque chez
l'influent second mari vers le business
l'agneby c'est cool d'être amis
page 200 pages je vais faire du mal que
ce qui se passe au stade mais à la fin
je sais pas si je fais là bas niveau
elle se fout de ma gueule à elle n'a
jamais à l'école donc ça un petit peu de
succès tout ça c'est quoi le problème on
est passé d'un portail mauvais accord
avec elle c'est ça mais ça donne quoi
[Applaudissements]
si tu regarde un peu autour de toi tu
fais un quart plein de gens qui t'aiment
moi je t'aime et je t'aimerai toujours
je suis là depuis le début
c'est très gênant style se poser
[Musique]